респект Українській правді і е Я Хочу
наголосити
наступне
дійсно Я і мої служби Звернулися до
лідерів держав які умовно відносить до
скептиків серед них є і Угорщина і
Словаччина і інша держави де я
запропонував
зустрітися обговорити ситуацію
для того щоби
переконати лідерів держав яких я дуже
добре
знаю Я маю дуже великий досвід проводити
позитивні рішення і в частині
ратифікації угоди по асоціацій в 14-му
15му 16му роках і ратифікацію угоди по
безвізовий режим і ратифікацію угоди по
поглибну та всеохоплюючу зону вільної
торгівлі і в тому числі і зараз
забезпечення прийняття рішення
єврокомісію про
початок переговорів про
членство декілька керівників держав та
урядів відповіли мені і
запросили ці зустрічі мали
відбутися їх було декілька в
листопаді я звернувся офіційно з
проханням дати в листопаді дозвіл на
виїзд мені було
відмовлено в грудні подібних зустрічей
не планувалося мені навмисно було
виділено в розпорядженні з 1 грудня ви
можете легко переконатися що частина
керівників європейських держав В цей
день і весь початок грудня і по досі
знаходяться на кліматичному саміті в
Еміратах
і в даному
випадку ще раз наголошую що з першого по
ме в мене були лише зустрічі в Польщі і
в Сполучених Штатах Америки
але країни де я планував зустрічатися з
керівництвом це є члени Європейського
Союзу це є члени
НАТО і сам факт членства зазначає їх
статус як наших партнерів Вони мають
голосувати за виділення нам 50 млрд євро
макрофінансової допомоги Вони мають
голосувати за те щоби запросити нас в
НАТО на вашингтонському саміті і з ними
мають працювати всі хто може всі хто і
знає для того щоби забезпечити
позитивний результат Я працюю над цим
все своє політичне життя а з 14го року
Це є мій перший пріоритет так само як
членство України в ЄС та нато крім
Перемоги нашої є засадничими позиціями
нашої політичної сили і нормами
Конституції Тому рішення яке було
прийнято воно було прийнято безглузде
безпідставне і таке яке дискредитує не
лише опозицію а демократію в Україні
і все ми ще наголошую не буде такого
коли голова верховної ради - Це не є
Голова колгоспу А голова Служби Безпеки
України не
є дільничим
НКВС який має щось підписувати або
дозволяти чи не дозволяти це безглуздо
Конституція каже що уряд є
підконтрольний і підзвітний
парламент а спроба деяких прихильників в
авторитарної моделі Кажуть що у нас уряд
тепер буде дозволяти депутатів тримаючи
їх на
гачку виїжджати чи не
виїжджати наша позиція уряд буде
підконтрольний Конституція відновить
свою дію ми будемо демократичною
державою ми я за це бився все своє
політичне життя і я з точки зору
демократії з точки зору перешкоджання
авторитаризму
не піду ні на які компроміси але зараз
ми маємо говорити не про те зараз у нас
перший пріоритет єдність єдність навколо
збройних сил єдність навколо нашого
вступу в ЄС та НАТО і припинити ці
дешеві політиканські трюки
які виходять з бажання тих чи інших
представників влади погратися на
рейтингах не
час прийнято рішення в тому числі в
якому брала участь пані Ірина в діалогах
мене що не проводити вибори я це
підтверджую підпис пані Ірини Там стоїть
і Пані Іванки Мені здається теж але там
була ще одна позиція що всі фракції
парламенту стоять за те щоби прибрати
рабську систему виїзду депутатів для
здійснення політичної діяльності в тому
числі і за кордон Хочу
наголосити що я не призначений
президентом так само і як наші колеги не
призначений урядом і ми несемо
відповідальність перед своїми виборцями
за реалізацію нашої передвиборчої
програми і подібні
дії некомпетентних людей я не знаю чим
вони керуються
Чи це кроти Чи це корисні ідіоти але це
точно не український
інтерес ще раз наголошую відповідаючи на
ваше питання що час зустрічі під час
мого виїзду вже минув мені не дали
дозволу на виїзд зустрічі були зірвані і
я з цього приводу не робив
прес-конференцій не робив заяв це все
зробили
е безглузді безвідповідальні
політикани які намагалися використати і
керівництво Верховної Ради мені соромно
за це парламент втратив суб'єктність і
керівництво СБУ мені теж соромно за це
ви можете саме легко здогадатися хто є
автором цієї провокації